Geometry is around us all the time!
It is so intricately involved in our day-to-
day life that we don’t even notice it.
How, you may ask?
Imagine that we were walking in a straight
line for one kilometre.
After that,
we turn left and walk 1 kilometre in this
direction.
Then again, we turn left and
walk 1 kilometre in this direction.
Now for the last time we turn left and walk
kilometre.
We would find that we are at the same place
we started from!
If we
trace our route, we would find that we walked
in a SQUARE shaped route!
This was only ONE example.
Geometry is hidden in natural patterns too!
Have you noticed the seeds in a
sunflower?
If you look closely, they form a spiral shaped
design.
Do you know
any other examples where you notice a spiral
pattern?
I know one…
spiral
galaxies!
These are types of galaxies that have a spiral
pattern, similar to our
sunflower seeds.
So we see that geometry is involved in things
as small as
sunflower seeds to things as big as galaxies!
Don’t you think it would be fun to study
these Geometrical shapes?
We have a very long history with the knowledge
of geometry.
From ancient
times, people were aware of geometry and used
it in their day-to-day life.
***
Let’s take an example of ancient Egypt.
Long ago, the people of ancient Egypt faced
a problem every year.
The
problem was that the Nile river used to flood
each year.
And whenever it
flooded, it used to destroy the boundaries
of land near the banks of the river.
This used to put the landowners in a problem!
After the flood, the boundaries
of lands would dissolve away.
So nobody would know which part of land
belonged to whom, and this would result in
confusion!
As this was an annual problem, they came up
with a system of measuring land
and redistributing it to the respective owners
after the flood.
This system of
measuring was one of the factors that gave
birth to the word GEOMETRY
which we study today.
The Indus Valley civilization around the year
3000 BCE also made use of
geometry.
Their cities were well planned, houses had
different types of rooms,
well planned roads and a good drainage system.
This was not possible if they
did not know the use of geometry.
Basically, geometry was being used in many
parts of the world throughout the
period.
The word GEOMETRY itself comes from the combination
of Greek words
“GEO” meaning LAND or EARTH, and “METREIN”
meaning MEASUREMENT.
So
GEOMETRY means the measurement of earth.
The geometry we study on paper today, was
actually conceived as a solution
for day-to-day problems in the ancient world.
The ancient Egyptians also used
geometry in construction, designing granaries
and making the pyramids!
So, all the existing knowledge about geometry
was brought together in a form
of a book by Euclid.
Euclid was a Greek mathematician who used
to teach
mathematics in the city of Alexandria, in
Egypt.
He was the first person to
collect all the work done on geometry and
put it together in books
called ‘Elements’.
His book contains definitions, axioms, postulates,
and proofs that we can use
to prove things further ahead in complex geometry.
We will try to cover some important definitions,
axioms and postulates from
his book that will help us in solving and
proving theorems to make our
understanding of geometry clearer.
So in the next lesson, we will learn about
some of the basic definitions in
geometry that Euclid put in his book named
‘ELEMENTS.’